today on the matt walsh show the
government is in the middle of an
all-out effort to find the people who
storm the capital and bring them to
justice but no such effort has been made
against the blm and antifa rioters
who've killed dozens and caused billions
of dollars of damage and it is this
hypocrisy this this inconsistency and
lack of equal justice that partly leads
to the writing in the first place
so it's worth talking about also five
headlines including the story of a woman
who identifies as a fairy and her two
lovers a troll and a leprechaun
classic love story and in our daily
cancellation we'll talk about president
trump's second impeachment
and why impeaching the president this
time is an even worse idea than it was
the first time
all of that and more today on the matt
wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
i'll take a second to tell you about
lifelock there's there's never been a
time where it's more important to
protect your online data
um it's a new year and that usually
means one thing new year's resolutions
that most of us
probably have a hard time keeping uh
well here's one resolution that's easy
to keep and you'll be glad
that you did it's really easy for you
because you only got to do one thing
really
get life luck life like identity theft
protection one out of every five
americans have
have been affected by identity theft
it's very common you think it's not
going to happen to you
but it very well could so this near this
new year you could miss
certain identity threats by just
monitoring your credit or monitoring
your bank statements that's a great
thing to do
but uh there's there's a lot more that
needs to be done that you're not able to
do that's why you need lifelock
a leader in identity theft protection
lifelock helps detect
a wide range of identity threats uh and
a lot of a lot of things that you
wouldn't necessarily
be able to detect on your own like if
your social security numbers being for
is for sale in the dark web that kind of
thing if they detect your information
being used in their networks
they'll send you an alert and you have
access to a us-based
identity restoration specialist to your
case if you should become a victim
so you've got you've got defense on one
end
but then you've also got it on the other
end too if you do become a victim you
have their identity
restoration specialist on call whenever
you need them
nobody can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions at all
businesses but lifelock is
the one new year's resolution that can
help resolve identity theft
join now and save 25 off your first year
go to lifelock.com
walsh that's lifelock.com walsh for 25
off so yesterday michael sherwin who's
the acting u.s attorney for dc announced
that he was building a case against a
number of the rioters on capitol hill
last week
one thing we've seen from the very
beginning is that the government at
every level
is is taking the incident extremely
seriously and arresting and prosecuting
all the culprits it can find number of
them including the dude who walked out
holding the speaker's lectern he's
already been arrested and frog marched
in front of
cameras another guy who breached the
capitol with a handful of zip ties and
his mom at his side
has also been arrested several others as
well with more coming
so here's sherwin explaining listen what
the
the public isn't familiar with is that
the fbi
working with the u.s attorney's offices
across the country
and the crux of those being in dc we're
looking at significant
felony cases tied to sedition and
conspiracy
just yesterday our office organized a
strike force of very senior national
security prosecutors
and public corruption prosecutors their
only marching orders from me are
to build seditious
and conspiracy charges related to the
most heinous
acts that occurred in the capital and
these are significant charges that have
felonies with uh prison terms of up to
20 years in addition to that we're
looking
in taking a priority with cases in which
weapons were involved
and cases in which destructive devices
were involved as people know
through news reports there were pipe
bombs found outside the capitol the atf
is working on that
metro police is working on that fbi is
working on that to find that individual
or individuals
who planted those devices yeah i think
he means
build sedition charges not build
seditious
charges that's a very different kind of
concept but this is all fine with me you
know you can argue about whether
sedition
is an overreach but frankly as far as
i'm concerned if you're stupid enough to
go storming into the capitol building
smiling for the cameras all the while
then you deserve the legal consequences
i will be crying no tears for
any of the idiots who made that choice
quite the opposite i believe in law and
order it isn't a slogan for me i want
people
who behave this way to face severe
repercussions i want that because
i want my kids to live in a functioning
and civilized human society
that's something i actually want i feel
like i'm in a minority now but i
actually want that
and they cannot have such a society if
chaos and anarchy are not contained and
punished
the problem here at least my problem is
that as we have covered on this show
extensively this
this same hammer should have been
brought down on the blm rioters and
insurrectionists to reign terror in our
cities for months on end
the you know the powers that be ought to
have made
them pay a steep price also we ought to
have been
hearing about 25-year prison sentences
for them
but we didn't instead we heard about
prosecutors dropping charges
we heard about democrat politicians
fundraising to pay for their bail
kamala harris being one of them an
entirely different standard of justice
is being applied and the reason for that
is obvious
for one the rioters over the summer had
the more popular the more
orthodox political views especially at
least in our society these days
also they mostly victimized their own
neighbors and their own communities
these were atrocities committed against
people that our elites don't
know in communities they don't care
about and
wouldn't even want to drive through in
the middle of the day so that's the
difference
but the point here is is not merely to
point out inconsistency in hypocrisy
it's worth doing that you know because
hypocrisy
shouldn't be allowed to hide in the dark
shedding light on it just for the sake
of shedding light on it is a worthwhile
thing to do
yet it only goes so far after a while
you've made your point about the
hypocrisy you've
you've said this is hypocritical what
else is there to say
um what else is there to do but to keep
saying what you've already said
well in this case there's a good reason
to dwell on the point i think
the reason is that the hypocrisy of the
elites
of our lawmakers politicians in dc their
self-interest their disregard for
everything that doesn't benefit them
politically the two-tiered justice
system
the double standard all of this is part
of what leads
to things like rioting or as it's called
when blm does it
unrest now i'm not referring just to the
events in dc last week i'm referring to
the general breakdown of order the
lawlessness and chaos across the board
this is an inevitability an entirely
predictable and unavoidable outcome
when people lose their faith in the
system and no longer have confidence
that justice is being done
and they feel as though they can't
believe anything they're told this is
not an excuse
for rioting or violence we have to be
able to talk about
these things and make observations about
them diagnose their causes
without being bullied into silence
because we're scared that we'll be
accused of
excusing it those who wish to miss the
point will but
it's just like if you were to park your
car in the city and leave your wallet
sitting in full view on the middle
console the person who breaks the window
and takes the wallet isn't excused for
doing it
but it would be perfectly reasonable for
me to point out that when you make the
choice that you made
you almost guarantee that this negative
thing will happen as a result so
don't make that choice so you look where
we are now
the country feels as though it's
teetering on the brink of full-scale
collapse
and there there is there is no one among
our leaders
and very few in media very few of the
public
platform of any size who can speak to
the problem
who can warn effectively against it and
call for calm because there's almost
nobody with any credibility at this
point
there's almost nobody who is trusted by
anyone let alone a majority
and when they try to dispel the
conspiracy theories that are driving
some of this stuff
there aren't many people who can dispel
them credibly
because they aren't trusted because
they're proven liars and hacks
and the response is oh you're telling me
that q isn't real well you also told me
trump was a secret russian agent for
four years
etc and so forth that's the way it goes
now
a country without trust without
leadership
that's what we're living in and we have
not yet seen
the worst of what will happen as a
result of that
let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
bad news for cnn by the way good news
for everybody else but
cnn's oliver darcy announced yesterday
that
the cnn airport network is going to end
operations as of march 31st so they're
saying that
like nobody's flying anymore so there's
no reason to have the the airport
the airports go the airport network
going but i just this is going to
how would how does this not spell the
end of cnn
because that was 95 of their audience
when you're stuck at an airport terminal
and as someone who does a lot of flying
this is great news for me because the
problem is when you're when you're
sitting in an airport terminal
and i don't know what it is exactly but
if there's something on the tv
you like you have to watch it there's
something psychologically that just
propels you
even if you can't hear the sound you
have to just keep your eyes glued
on brian stelter's face
but our suffering as a nation is coming
to an end
uh cnn will be gone from the airports
march 31st that's when that's when our
national nightmare ends
so that's good news let's get to the
real headlines though number one from
the daily wire it says government
subsidized broadcaster pbs
released a statement tuesday in reaction
to an explosive video from
james o'keefe's project veritas that
featured an employee advocating for
trump supporters to be sent to
re-education camps
and also advocated for the forcible
removal of their children by the
government
statement announced that this employee
no longer works for pbs as a mid-level
staff attorney he did not speak on
behalf
of our organization nor did he make any
editorial decisions
um so this now this now former employee
is pbs principal counsel michael beller
and uh here's what we'll play some of
the audio that project veritas got of
him um
just revealing what he really thinks and
how he really feels
this again is someone who worked for pbs
government subsidized
let's listen to some of this
and we'll put them into re-educational
unique
uh it's actually the first time i've
watched that so he said it's a little
bit hard to hear
but he said uh we we need to put trump
supporters
children in re-education camps
uh he compared trump to hitler
yeah and then later on he talks about
how you know so many people in the
country are stupid and he likes being in
dc
because he gets to be around smart
people so
uh just what here's the thing with stuff
like that i i i don't know
whenever one of these videos comes out
um
of the secret tape of somebody in media
talking about how they really feel and
oftentimes the reaction from
conservatives
there's like a big reaction from
conservatives and we make a big deal of
it but
i see these kind i'll be honest i i
listen to these tapes and i just sort of
yawn i don't see well yeah
of course i know they feel that way
there's nothing shocking about that to
me
at all i'm fully aware that
nearly everyone who works in mass media
that is exactly how they feel
they think that we're all a bunch of
stupid bumpkins
uh they think trump is hitler i mean
they say that on tv so there's nothing
shocking about that
um they think we're not fit to raise our
own kids our kids should be sent to
re-education camps that's what public
school system is by the way
so if you're if you're traumatized or
scandalized by the idea of
kids being sent to re-education camps
and you send your kid to public school
well you're doing it right now as we
speak
um so i i guess i i just don't often see
the point
yeah i i get it i know that's how they
feel
all right i mean i don't like it i can't
say i'm okay with it but
i am aware that that's the situation and
that's why
i don't turn to these people for
information or news
personally all right let's go to number
two ilhan omar
is speaking out about the trauma that
she has suffered
and about the fact that she is
marginalized which is one of her
favorite types well her favorite topic
is herself in general but
especially her her marginalization that
she suffers in society
let's listen to that as you know the
last two years the president has put
a target behind my on my back and
it has been quite frightening to be a
lawmaker in the united states with a
president
that has incited violence
against myself and my family and those
who carry the marginalized identities
that i do
those who carry the marginalized
identities that i do
you carry an identity around something
you carry around like a like
you know like a suitcase uh marginalized
you're not only in congress but
you are far away one of the most
visible and influential members of
congress for better or worse and i would
say for worse
for for worse for the rest of us and for
america but not for you
so now you just you gotta i know it's
hard right i know it's hard to do if
you're ilhan omar
and identity politics self-victimization
this is in your blood
this is this is this is what you live
for right this your your whole life
um and so it's hard to put it to the
side but you really need to
because now you're in government you
have control and power over other people
just a general rule if you're elected to
congress
it means you're not marginalized that
whatever margin
whatever it means to be marginalized i'm
pretty sure that being elected to public
office
is the opposite of being marginalized
meanwhile donald trump uh spoke
yesterday
about a few things um the 25th amendment
threats
being one of the one of the things and
he he made a point about 25th amendment
that i thought was pretty good so let's
listen to that before we begin i'd like
to say that free speech is
under assault like never before the 25th
amendment
is of zero risk to me but will come back
to haunt
joe biden and the biden administration
as the expression goes
be careful what you wish for
the impeachment hoax is a continuation
of the greatest and most vicious witch
hunt
in the history of our country and is
causing tremendous anger and division
and pain
far greater than most people will ever
understand
which is very dangerous for the usa
especially
at this very tender time
yeah i think the point made there is
exactly correct the 25th amendment is
supposed to
remove presidents who are incapacitated
presidents who are
not able to perform the duties of of the
presidency
whatever you think of trump you think
that trump is the most evil guy
in the world that doesn't that doesn't
mean that he's incapacitated or cannot
perform the duties of the president
that's not the 25th amendment is not
supposed to be for that for for just
removing someone because
uh you think he's just a really bad guy
um but if you want to talk about a
president who can't perform his duties
who's incapacitated
that we we could very well see that
happen with joe biden
that is a that's a a prediction that we
may see play out now as far as the 25th
amendment goes
uh mike pence vice president pence
sent a letter to nancy pelosi because it
was being demanded that he
you know initiate this process and vote
the 25th amendment to get rid of
trump and he responded sent a letter
i thought it was a short letter but it
was good and to the point and he said
i'm not going to do that
that would be unconstitutional i'm not
going to do it so i i have to tell you
you look at the situation that mike
pence has been put in
over the last just the last week alone
now i've been really impressed with him
i've been impressed with him through the
last four years
um especially the last couple of months
i thought he was great in the debates
but then you look at just the last week
where he has been put twice now in a
week
in an unthinkably difficult position
where doing the right thing meant
infuriating
first one side of the aisle and then the
other
for you know last week uh it was
pissing off the the right wing and many
conservatives who now call him a traitor
wrongly by the way uh and now it's the
left wing
and in both cases i've been very
impressed with how he handled it
um i think he's shown himself to be a
man of
integrity he's you know he's not a
showman
he's not into the theatrics he goes
about his business in a really sort of
boring way
which i'm perfectly fine with i i kind
of like boring from politicians i'm fine
with that
but he does the right thing he did the
right thing both both times here
uh so i think he deserves mike pence
deserves credit for that although he's
not going to get it
from from almost anyone on on either
side
all right this is from reuters it says
the fbi has warned of armed protests
being planned for washington and all 50
u.s states u.s state capitals in the
run-up to
president-elect joe biden's inauguration
january 20th
it's according to a federal law
enforcement source threatened with war
violence from the outgoing
president donald trump supporters blah
blah blah that's reuters okay
um the point is that they're
what we're being told now is that uh
trump's
supporters are organizing these armed
protests
some of the reports are we're going to
have them in all 50 states that that's
not going to happen um
and then others are saying well it's
just going to be another big thing in
d.c
i don't know how much of this is real if
there's really going to be armed
protests all over the place
um but
you know i haven't heard the people that
i know and talk to i haven't heard
anyone
saying that they plan on attending
something like that but i can tell you
right now
for the record uh if you're on the right
and you go to something like that
especially in dc
on inauguration day you are waltzing
right into a trap
so that that would be an enormously
stupid thing to do
to attend something like that especially
on the day of the inauguration
and aside from protests i just want to
say even if there are no big protests or
anything
um what i what i would really hope
my hope is i hope to god that there are
no scenes
on inauguration day when biden's being
inaugurated i hope there are no scenes
of any conservatives or anybody on the
right
crying and screaming in the streets
because they're so distraught by what's
happening
because if you recall that's exactly
what the left did when trump was
inaugurated
some very famous scenes we know the one
famous scene of the woman on
on the ground her falling to her knees
hands in the air screaming no to the sky
that is something that will live in
infamy that image
uh that the the left has been branded by
that image
and and for good reason because they've
lived up to that it encapsulates how
they've behaved over the last four years
now up until recently i would have
thought it's unthinkable
that the right would would do that i
wasn't worried about it at all
now i'm a little bit worried about it so
let's not do that let's maintain
let's be calm let's be dignified um
let's be let's maintain self-respect
and you know keep our cool so we don't
embarrass ourselves that would be my
my urging to everybody all right this is
from the new york post so this is part
of education the department of education
ended the suspense around
uh this is in new york around around the
city's accelerated gifted and talented
program tuesday night
announcing that the single test entry
system will end after this year parents
have been clamoring for answers on the
coveted program
that admits uh kids based on
standardized exam scores beginning at
age four
backers say they give academically
advanced kids so these are the kids that
are
tagged as gifted and talented that's the
name of the program
uh backers say the the tests give
academically advanced kids the
opportunity to learn at an appropriate
pace and serve as an
educational springboard detractors
counter the admissions model favors
families of means who are able to
uh prepare for the task that the exam
serves as a poor marker of talent and
young children
and then it goes on to say that it gets
into the racial element and it's claimed
that this
gifted and talented program was somehow
racist
putting that to the side putting the the
racial elements to the side
and this is something i can remember
growing up in school we had we had
something similar we had a gifted and
talented program
where you you got into it by testing you
had to take
standardized tests and if you got the
right answers on the test and you know
you
they'd test you i don't know if it was
every year i can't remember but
periodically you'd be tested again and
if you got the right answers to the test
and you did well in the test
then you're gifted and talented you're a
gifted and talented kid
and then these but these other kids are
not they're not gifted and talented
maybe it might surprise you to learn i i
i'm i am in favor of getting rid of
those kinds of systems also
now i know we don't want to this you
could go too far with this
you know some school districts like in
san diego they're getting rid of grading
completely
because they don't want to hurt the kids
feelings that obviously is absurd
but i do think it's a problem when
you've got all these kids in school to
take some kids set them aside and say
these are the gifted and talented ones
if you don't do well on this test you're
not gifted and talented
my problem with it is that a test
and this is one of the problems with the
the education system as it functions
right now generally
but a standardized test is simply not a
good measure of whether or not a child
is gifted and talented
your kid could do really well on tests
and have
no talent and really not be all that
gifted
their ability to perform well on tests
that that is that speaks to their
ability to memorize things and
regurgitate
them which okay let's only let me back
up that is one that is a talent
so they have one talent fine
uh it's certainly not the most important
talent to foster in a child doesn't make
them smarter
and so the more we standardize education
and everything relies on tests then we
we reward students who do well in this
one
facet of learning which isn't even
really learning because just because you
can remember something regurgitate it
doesn't mean you understand it
um so i i i think that's a good
a good idea to get rid of things like
that to get rid of systems like that
and if you want to identify the kids who
are really gifted and talented
and put them on a different track so
they're not you know so so they can
learn at a speed and a level that's
appropriate for them
i don't think testing is the way to do
it at least not these kinds of
standardized tests
all right number five the hosts of the
show this morning on bbc
interviewed a woman uh this is a couple
in
i i think they're in i want to say
they're in seattle or portland
i believe i'm probably just stereotyping
but i'm
i i would guess accurately so a woman
who identifies as a fairy
and who's in a sexual relationship with
a man who identifies as a troll and also
another man so it's a throuple
and there's another man who identifies
as a leprechaun and they're all together
one happy family and uh here's some of
that
interview that we all need to watch here
it is princess a fairy lolly
gunther the troll and i on the
leprechaun join us now from their home
in seattle
and good morning it is so lovely to have
you here on the show welcome
good morning good morning good morning
good morning good morning
so let's start with you first of all uh
princess lolly if you don't mind
now you identify as a full-time fairy so
just explain
what life is like
so yes as a full-time fairy that it is
basically my duty all the time
to traipse about it in the land of real
as we refer to it and
spread what fairy magic i can hither and
yawn
primarily that takes place at
our fairy festival that we produce which
is fairy blossom
and other renaissance fairest festivals
and then also
because of covet this year we have
really
launched forth via the youtube portals
and and when did you discover that you
actually were a fairy
many years ago we don't like to count
too much
in you know how counting goes and time
and fairies but
we shall say it has been some time since
when i was a young lady okay so let's
introduce us
to you you've got um gunther i think we
all get the idea
you got the gist of it there it is uh i
have to say
that i i mean i can relate to the fairy
in in some ways
she says it's her mission to traipse
about in the land of real and spread
fairy magic in many ways you know i
i think of myself in a similar way
spreading fairy magic
that's what i do with this show i hope
that's my goal
i do it on a part-time basis though this
woman identifies as a full-time fairy so
that's
that's uh that's an important
distinction and it sets her apart from
one of her boyfriends there who uh
we didn't hear from in the clip but he
identifies as a leprechaun only
part-time so we've got a troll full-time
leprechaun part-time
and you know what love is love you
bigots that's it
and besides there's there's nothing
objectively more absurd about this than
about the left's gender theories they're
at least
as ridiculous and besides i think that
they were mainly just trying to promote
their renaissance festival
on second thought watching that again
which for me raises questions about
renaissance festivals
i've never i've never been to one but
i thought the idea at a renaissance
festival was supposed to be a
celebration of the renaissance period in
history isn't that what it was supposed
to be
and they didn't like actually have
fairies and trolls in the renaissance
period
you're thinking of middle earth which is
a common mistake but it's
very different but the point again is
that even with something like this
um if they are being serious about it
there is
zero basis to deny their self-identity
as mythical creatures
with the way we think of identity these
days anyway
you know one of the worst sounds that we
all experience is unfortunately the
first sound we hear in the morning is
our alarm going off it means we have to
get up and
face another day in this dreary world uh
it's especially hard to hear if you've
been if you
have helix sleep if you have a helix
sleep mattress that alarm because
you're sleeping so deep and it just
yanks you out of that sleep
uh that's why you need to get a helix
sleep magic mattress helix sleep has a
quiz that takes just two minutes to
complete
and it matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you
if you like a mattress that's really
soft or firm you sleep on your side or
your back
uh if you get really hot while you're
sleeping whatever it is with helix
there's a specific mattress for each and
everybody's unique taste uh
you don't need to take the word for it
either why do that helix was awarded
the number one best overall mattress of
2019 and 2020 by gq
and wired magazine just go to
helixsleep.comwalsh
take their two-minute sleep quiz i've
done it myself
and they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your of your life i was
skeptical at first taking the quiz
because there's not that many questions
and i thought
are this really going to be enough for
them to send me a mattress that's
perfect for me
then they sent the mattress and the
answer is yes it's a perfect mattress
right now helix is offering up to 200
off and free pillows with all mattress
orders
for our listeners at walsh that's helix
sleep.com
walls for up to 200 off your mattress
order
and tomorrow night daily wire makes its
entrance
into entertainment content uh at 7 p.m
eastern 4 p.m pacific we will air
a virtual premiere of our first feature
film run hide fight in a special episode
of backstage you don't want to miss this
the premiere will stream live over at
dailywire.com at our website
also on the streaming apps and on our
youtube channel all of that after
tomorrow's event
the movie will be available exclusively
to daily wire members
so please be aware run hide fight is not
a political film
it is intense though and it's for mature
audiences only the movie follows a high
school siege by a quartet of school
shooters when one young girl 17 year old
zoe hall uses her wits and survival
skills to fight back
this is not your typical conservative
documentary about george washington's
mother's cousin nothing against those by
the way i'm very interested in george
washington's mother's cousin but
uh this is not that this is something
very different we're excited to bring it
to you we're excited to bring you great
stories that hollywood
refuses to acknowledge and show and we
hope you'll join us for this special
event tomorrow night at 7 p.m eastern 4
pm pacific at dailywire.com apple tv or
roku or the daily wire youtube channel
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
so today for our daily cancellation
we're going to cancel everybody involved
in the impeachment efforts
efforts currently underway in the house
uh the articles of impeachment released
last night charged donald trump with
incitement of insurrection and other
crimes as well now usually the daily
cancellation
is reserved for things that aren't very
serious this is a time for content
that's
maybe a bit more farcical than the rest
of the show and and that's
in fact actually why it's a good place
to discuss the democrats second
impeachment of trump
which is indeed a farce unserious a
political stunt
so here are the problems with impeaching
trump as far as i can see
at least two of the problems first of
all no matter what you think of the fact
that trump was
claiming voter fraud and the fact that
he called for a rally in dc and the fact
that he
you know sent the crowd over the capitol
building you can't get around
uh the fact that that trump did
specifically call for a peaceful protest
in his remarks of the crowd
you could check the transcript i have
and here's what the transcript says
here's what he said
we have come to demand that congress do
the right thing and only count the
electors who have been lawfully slated
i know that everyone here will soon be
marching over to the capitol building to
peacefully and patriotically make your
voices heard
that's what he said now you might argue
that he didn't really mean it
you might argue that he didn't really
care what would happen can argue all
that
you might be wrong you might be right
but the fact still remains that he did
explicitly and verbally call for a
peaceful protest
we have seen lawmakers encourage
violence
and riots explicitly we know what that
sounds like
the democratic state representative in
michigan a few weeks ago we played that
clip uh
calling on quote-unquote soldiers to
find trump supporters and quote make
them
pay okay that if trump had said to the
crowd
find these lawmakers and make them pay
okay now you got a case that is
obviously incitement ayanna presley
during the blm riots calling for more
quote unrest in the streets
once again if trump had said go to the
capitol building and there needs to be
unread if he had said
there has to be unrest at the capitol
building in order to uh
prevent this from happening once again
you have a case
alexandria ocasio-quez cortez blasting
the people who called for an end to the
unrest
claiming that to call for an end to the
unrest is to call for injustice to
continue that's what she said
maxine waters telling her supporters to
track down trump administration
officials in public and
to create a crowd and let them know they
aren't welcome anywhere those are direct
quotes
all of these and much more are examples
of explicit incitement
direct incitement as it happens
all of the people guilty of it now
support impeaching trump for allegedly
doing
what they unquestionably have done
themselves
if you want to argue that it's
incitement
simply to get a potentially unruly crowd
riled up with dubious claims and to send
them out to
sort of broadly fight for this or that
then
again the democrats behind this
impeachment would be guilty of the same
even the ones who didn't explicitly
endorse rioting were still spreading the
false claims that fueled the riots
and encouraging the rioters to continue
the fight for social justice
so before the democrats can even begin
to make a case for impeachment
all of those guilty of doing these
things
would need to admit their guilt and
resign
that's what they would have to do do
that first here's the deal that i would
make
if i had any power at all which i don't
uh do that first
if you're a democrat and you were guilty
of incitement yourself by your own
standard guilty of it
by the standard you're now applying to
trump if you did it yourself resign
and then i'm willing to listen to the
impeachment case
from the three or four democrats who
remain in office
that should be the deal if the
republicans had any sense
any backbone in his spine that's what
they would be saying
they should be saying absolutely let's
let's let's get rid of everybody
who's been guilty of inciting riots
during this time of chaos and anarchy
because it's it's it's it's enough we
have to put an end to it um so let's get
rid of all of them and let's start with
you guys
that's what they should be saying second
point all that aside
um or not aside but at least uh you know
i i make this point as an important
addition to the previous donald trump is
out of office
in a week seven days that's it
he'll be gone regardless and i would bet
everything i own
that trump is not gonna run again in
2024 at the age of 78
after all of this i mean he may say he
will
he maybe he may make noises to that
effect over the next four years but
i don't think he's really going to do it
so this is not even an effort to remove
him from office
because he's going to be gone before the
senate trial can begin and i don't buy
that this is about stopping him from
running again in fact
i think the democrats would love for
trump to run again they're terrified of
the prospect of having to exist now on
their own
without being able to define themselves
by their opposition to trump
they can't even remember what it was
like to have a political ideology that
wasn't defined by trump
so this isn't about removing him
from office because again he'll already
be gone and it isn't about stopping him
from running again
this is rather symbolic it is theater
it is impeachment as theater and it's
not the first time the democrats have
done it
the people who have pretended to be so
concerned about norms and about
protecting the democratic system and
so on have now turned impeachment which
is an essential tool
into a meaningless empty gesture
two presidents in nearly 250 years had
been impeached before trump
the democrats have now impeached trump
twice
in almost a year meaning they've done it
as many times in a year
as every congress in history had done it
before this
they have doubled the number of
impeachment in in a year they've doubled
it
so that means it's been cheapened the
the the tool of impeachment has been
cheapened
to the point of uselessness what this
means now is that
impeachment will be used commonly if the
opposing party controls the house
uh it'll be used just to make a
political point because that's what it's
become now
what was once rare what was once nearly
unthinkable
will now be utterly commonplace a matter
of course
you know we had we have now four
impeachments in 20 250 years it was two
now we have four
the next 20 years we'll probably see
that many we'll probably double it
another 20 years
if not more because of what they've done
with this tool of impeachment and again
an essential tool
now it means nothing because of what
democrats have done
because they are using it as just
symbolism
and that's why um i think we should all
be opposed to impeachment no matter how
you feel about trump
that's why we should all be opposed to
it and that's why the democrats are
canceled
certainly not not for the first time and
certainly not for the last time i
suspect
but we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening have a great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is our mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadasky
the show is edited by danny d'amico our
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by nika geneva and
production assistant mckenna waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
dailywire2021
today on the ben shapiro show democrats
pushed forward with impeachment in the
house
as republicans argue over how to respond
we'll go through all of the arguments
pro and con
that's today on the bench hero show tune
in